des parents se mobilisent pour empêcher
la fermeture de six des sept garderie de
la commission scolaire de montréal
premier objectif obtenir un moratoire
d'abord afin de garder les garderies
ouverte
émilie dubreuil explique save à la
garderie rejoint les amis victoria
n'était pas encore né que jessica ben
que l'inscrivait sur des listes
d'attentes pour obtenir une place en
garderie après son congé de maternité si
l' angoisse
personne ne la rappelle dans le réseau
quand j'ai reçu l'appel lagarde école
qui la garderie dans l'école primaire on
m'a fait va aller j'avais l'impression
d'avoir gagné à la loterie
or depuis mars victoria et sa maman
livrent bataille touche pas à ma
garderie dit le macaron qu'elles portent
toutes les deux sur leur manteau car en
mars dernier les commissaires ont décidé
que ces garderies en milieu scolaire
coûtait trop cher et prenait trop de
place d'ici 2016 on va donc éliminé 185
places 6 garderie qui existait depuis 30
ans et on envoie les parents au
ministère de la famille et nous renvoie
aux bureaux coordonnateurs le bureau
coordonnateur va nous envoyer ou sur les
sept enfants sam et points or qui nous
donnerons pas de place alors c'est
vraiment vraiment panika pour les
parents du quartier
ces garderies avaient été installés dans
des écoles du plateau de jaga
maisonneuve en jour aux mans et viau
alors que le taux de natalité était au
plus bas et les écoles vide n'est
justement le vent a tourné et les écoles
primaires de certains arrondissements ne
fournissent plus à la demande
c'est 1000 élèves de plus par année
pendant une décennie
mais déjà pour septembre on s'attend
plus calmes et l'on s'attend bien 500
gmail élèves de plus alors qu'on en
compte aujourd'hui 45 milles aux
primaires ça demande la place dans cette
école de notre dame de grâce on a ajouté
11 classes pour l'an prochain et des
chantier d'agrandissement il y en a 27
dans les écoles de la csdm en ce moment
il ya évidemment ce qu'on appelle un
petit baby boom des dernières années
puis à l'immigration à montréal qui les
amène de nouveaux enfants manquent de
place manque d'argent les parents qui
vont perdre leurs places dans les
garderies de la csdm n'achète pas ses
arguments il pense plutôt que la
commission scolaire est tout simplement
mal gérée autrement dit qu'il ya moyen
de moyenner ses contenus à prendre des
décisions aberrantes comme ceux qui ont
pas de logique qui ont pas de sens on on
va faire des moyens de pression au
niveau des élections les prochaines
élections scolaires auront lieu en
novembre prochain
émilie dubreuil radio canada montréal